there's a lot of push towards being a
workaholic and hard work is a learned
behavior I see it in my team I've seen
it in the thousands of employees I've
had which is the closer they are to the
Sun the harder they work and I'm like
Aha and so I definitely feel like I
learned hard work by watching my parents
and so it's why I talk so much about
hustle I watch people give advice
completely predicated on natural talent
and DNA and I'm like look I get it like
I can throw a football every day for
nine hours a day I'm just not physically
built to be competitive at the highest
levels yeah I do think if anybody
watching right now if there's anything
they take away it's like look like
you're gonna only be so pretty you're
only going to be so smart there's things
that are gonna be natural and then
there's things that you can actually
control I do believe and I don't know if
I'm right or wrong I don't but I do
believe that work ethic is a taught
Behavior it's something you do have more
control over and you know what really
sealed the deal for me getting healthier
I was 38 years old and it didn't come
natural to me like it didn't come
natural to me at all I hate the gym I
hate it now I hate it I don't like it I
don't want to do it but I knew it was
important and somewhere around Midway
through being 38 years old I got serious
I figured out my system I made the
financial commitment and I've won need
motivation watch a top ten with believe
Nation hey it's Evan Carmichael and I
make these videos because you are
probably the most ambitious person in
your circle but you know you're capable
of more and you get that Push by
surrounding yourself with the best so
today let's learn from one of the best
Gary vaynerchuk and my take on his top
10 rules of success enjoy
rule number two treat your health well
30 and a half I'm on this random play
I'm just laying there not feeling tired
not feeling lethargic not cliche thing
no heartburn that I think I'm getting a
heart attack nothing
I'm just laying there and I'm saying you
know
if I treated my health
the way I treated businesses
I'd win and so I just started actually I
don't remember what happened because I
was like that's not doesn't feel right I
was thinking about my 40th birthday and
I was thinking you know at 30 I changed
my life I went from the executor to I
need to go for it if I don't do from 30
to 40 it's not going to happen so let me
go for it in that decade
and I was like what am I gonna do at 40.
weirdly I don't feel the same pressure I
did at 30. I think I'm on a better
career path like I don't feel The Angst
to like it didn't feel right to Triple
down on work and so I said
health health is nowhere close to where
it should be I'm not I'm I'm the way I
make fun of people in business you're
not doing anything right that's going to
help you long term I'm not doing
anything right with health when I turn
40. I'm going to get serious
so then a week later I'm on a flight
again flights made me think and I'm like
am I waiting to 44. I could do a lot of
bad in this next 18 months 39 in
November this is around May and in
November I'm going to go for it and
literally the next morning I'm like why
rule number three stop complaining life
is broken down into complaining and not
so if you're not complaining
well then I have no I have no advice for
you but I'm pumped like you did it like
like I have friends who make forty two
thousand dollars a year
um work nine to four
kind of with an hour and a half lunch
and 45 minutes of YouTube and 10 minutes
of [ __ ] and an hour of complete
wasted time in a meeting so they're kind
of working like six you know hours a
week right but
but they're pumped right and and and
they text me these are high school
friends and they'll text me like how
happy they are to be the coach of their
kids baseball team
and you know like that's amazing like
that that seems very obvious to me like
that's like that's right like
you know what's super weird I'm actually
weirdly envious you know like I it
sounds cool like in theory right Grass
Is Always Greener right like far less
pressure you know like like all that
time with my kids that would be cool
like there's just like all these things
that I can justify so to me but I have
friends who have 100 million dollars in
the bank because of Facebook's IPO who
complain who are still hungry who want
to do even more who will complain to me
because they know I work a lot about no
work life balance and they don't get to
spend enough time with their family and
I'm like you have a hundred million
dollars
like you could stay home like you're in
control like you don't complain about it
you've made that choice don't [ __ ]
me like you want to spend more time with
your family spend more time with your
family rule number four don't focus on
one thing who gets to decide what focus
is I have a wine company a shoe deal
content vaynermedia the Wine Library
garyvee baseball cards I'm trying to
sell garage sale I'm the least focused
focused [ __ ] you'll ever meet
[Applause]
guys if you're a real entrepreneur you
kind of can't just do one thing
that's how we're [ __ ] up right like
I'm gonna come up with three business
ideas in the next hour
and I'm gonna do that every day and I'll
probably do two of them in the year
because that's what makes us happy also
to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five be confident when
you look yourself in the mirror what do
you see and what do you say to yourself
probably the most egotistical things
that I say
I'm probably most egoed out when I'm
talking to myself
which means that I've got a lot of
confidence and ego I really I really
whenever I talk to myself in a mirror
it's always the same thing which is like
you're gonna do it man you're man you're
good like like it's real good stuff and
it's not like false pumping up I only do
it seven times a year but like something
would have just happened either
adversity or something great and I'll
look myself and say
we got this I got a funny Kevin Durant
walked off the field off the court the
other day against the uh Warriors
and uh it was a big game day before the
Super Bowl and they lost the first time
I played in The Warriors are having
probably the greatest Seasons right
and he did something that me and AJ took
note of he kind of shook his head and
said okay yeah
and he gave me that like okay do you won
but we'll see you and we got a shot I
got this right and it was that's what I
do with myself like if something good or
bad is happening I'll look myself in the
mirror and be and I'll just say like I
know I'm built for this rule number six
don't judge yourself do you feel like
you judge yourself I don't that's a very
very very good observation and it's what
I want for everybody else we're beating
ourselves up
like everybody sucks at something right
like we all have shortcomings and we all
have strengths and for me it's like why
don't we just audit that like why don't
we just look at it that way and be like
all right well I'm good at this but I'm
not good at that like and then and then
and then I only focus what I'm good at
right like I don't dwell that I can't
fix [ __ ] around the house I'd call
somebody to fix it like I'm not like I'm
not a man I don't give a [ __ ] like you
know like like you know like I don't I
don't get it like we all like I also
think it's awesome that I'm so
emotionally stable and I'm the emotional
backbone of everybody is that what a
dude's supposed to do like like these
cliches these stereotypes they're so
silly
um you're exactly right man I don't
judge myself I'm fully in love with
myself
but I'm also fully in love with
everybody else too right it's not like
like it goes both ways like I tell
people to buy into me that work for me
it's because I buy into them first
like I don't need anybody to gain trust
with me I it's there like I believe that
the human race is so grossly underrated
we are good of course we have some bad
there's seven billion of us
but like when you look at our Net score
it's Bonkers [ __ ] like do you know which
damage we could be doing to each other
on an hourly basis and we don't like
we're still here like we won we're the
alpha being and we've figured out how to
stay together this is insane when you
think about it
and yet everybody wants to dwell on like
somebody said something mean rule number
seven live life on your terms and you
don't think it's possible to to to grow
the entrepreneur I do I think it's
possible to grow anything I think that I
could be a better singer in three years
I think that I could be a better
basketball player do I think I can
become Beyonce and LeBron even if I
started at six years old no I do not
yeah that's right and so but you have a
better chance of being
a notch a master entrepreneur than a
master basketball player I don't know I
don't know is how I answered that I do
think that salesmanship and
organizational understanding and reverse
engineering and pattern recognition is
absolutely a talent and I think Grant
it's funny you asked me that I think we
in the world have accepted music and
sports as a pure play talent and I think
entrepreneurship is something we think
everybody has and I do think everybody
can
and by the way I think it's phenomenal
to go from working at a job and not
being on your own rules to making a
business that makes eighty nine thousand
dollars a year but you get to do it your
way in a world where people need to be
more practical meaning not everybody's
going to be a millionaire it's just the
truth the data's against you but it is
phenomenal to live a life where you get
to make the rules and you make enough
money to live your life rule number
eight follow the 5149 principle
5149 I would run a 51 I'd run a slash
and I run a 49. what's it mean
it would mean that I wanted to give
everybody that ever came across me 51 of
the value
and that's how I live my life I so know
what to do with the 49 that I want to
give 51. it's leverage
it's um it's how I think about it it
makes me feel good I love being liked I
Lewis look you and I run in similar
circles and around a lot of different
you know you know what I'm about to say
is so true and I'm very proud of this
and I am saying this because I want
everybody to hear it do you know how
nice it feels for me to know that
anybody that you talk to when my name
gets brought up that knows me even a
little bit thinks I'm great and only the
people that don't
don't like whatever I have in hate or
they don't believe the hype or what's he
really about they just don't know me
yeah and anybody that spent any amount
of time like listen there could be
moments in time but I know that the 137
times I've been brought up in different
cocktail parties or things that that you
you've rarely heard from somebody who's
interacted with me
negative it's always been positive and I
love that yeah and that's 51.49 man rule
number nine do things for the long term
you can't be all time if you didn't have
results you can't just say you're one of
the great I can't say I'm one of the
greatest Batman players of all time if I
didn't do it yeah first you have to do
it yeah yeah um but the way he or she
does that is by putting themselves in
the best position to succeed
I met a kid last night business went
from zero to five million dollars in
sales in two minutes all Instagram all
the [ __ ] I spewed I saved his life he's
I'm the best I'm 27 Gary I'm high energy
I'm just like you and by the time I'm 30
I'm gonna be a billionaire and I stopped
them I said why are you even doing that
first of all you're probably not because
you're 27 you got five million I don't
see anything that gets you to a billion
in your behavior right now number two
you pulled off a unbelievable thing and
you're downplaying your success because
you're telling smart people like me
you're gonna hit a billion and 30 and in
three years I'm gonna see you and you're
not gonna hit a billion and you've put
set yourself for a loss and most of all
and this is why I'm telling the story
truly are convincing yourself that
you're going to hit a billion by the
time you're 30 and you're at 5 million
from zero at 27 and you're not going to
pull it off all your behavior for the
next 36 months is going to be predicated
on short-term Behavior not long-term
Behavior and the best way to make real
money wealth not being rich is to do
things for the long term because his
life continues at 31. and Rule Number 10
the last one before a very special bonus
clip is find Merit in feedback I think
that too many people when somebody says
something they don't like to hear
dismiss it as hate and a troll I read it
and question it and then decide is there
any Merit to it and the reason I've been
able to evolve is because I don't just
default if somebody disagrees with me or
makes fun of me that they're wrong I try
to be thoughtful about what are they
doing nine out of ten times it's because
they're in a bad place and they're just
trying to drag me down but occasionally
there's a point there that I kind of
fester in and start subconsciously
adjusting what I'm doing feedback is
important
two things I want to do
when I do cell phone because we are
trying to Aug up our social media
presence here and wherever you are uh so
if you get out your phone and follow Joe
Todd on Instagram and I'd like the
Facebook page for PRN Roofing my
question bro hold on hold on
did you really think that was a good
idea
no bro I honestly think that that was
one of like the worst moves I've ever
seen because
foreign
I'm
trying to give you love I love the
passion to win the problem is you tried
to close on the first move
you brought them no value and you asked
them to bring you value
like you gave like I will stand up here
and give a [ __ ] load of value and never
mention one time for any of them to
follow me and a lot more of them will
follow me that are going to follow that
[ __ ] move that you just did
foreign
I get it I get it but this was back to
the question that just happened this is
why I want you to win that move is
always going to lose you can't go
tonight when you go out in Vegas and you
see a pretty girl at the bar you can't
go up to her and the opening move is
like here's my key let's go
business because this is an industry
where it's kind of like world so why why
are you succeeding and giving all your
secrets away at the same time I mean
because doing the right thing is the
right thing karma is practical
[Applause]
you know I heard somebody rant earlier
right that was like Hey when I win I
don't think it's coming out of you the
guy that closed I couldn't know who was
on stage but I believe in that right
because I love the idea of 85 people
here going and listening to me winning I
didn't make anything for it but it then
becomes brand if she goes out and
listens and then two years later she's
having dinner with a friend and she's
talking about what happened to her life
that friend might be the CEO of GE you
know I'm playing with the biggest brands
in the world I'm not trying to monetize
my audience I'm trying to like just
bring the most value in the world and
let that lift all my other opportunities
so I think I think giving away your best
Secrets is the greatest strategy for two
reasons karma is practical and leads to
more business but here's the secret and
it's even funnier 99 of these people are
not going to do anything about it
the re somewhere about five or six years
ago I realized this fact holy [ __ ]
people aren't going to do anything with
this
so like there's still gonna be plenty
for me and I'm gonna be the most lovable
guy ever I love this so
you know how do you balance clouds in
the dirt and which do you focus on more
and why so to find everybody how I
Define clouds and dirt clouds to me is
like the why the strategy the macro the
big thinking the big picture the
operating system of like how you do
things and then the dirt is having the
humility to go to these meetings to
actually I post on my Instagram photos
the doing the the humility ego humility
strategy execution clouds and dirt uh
the way I balance it is they're both
important at all times I can swing back
and forth to them I can literally go
from a meeting where like the call I had
on the way out to our first meeting here
today Purell was with vaynermedia's
c-suite about a restructuring of how we
handle all our business super meta and
then literally hung up and I posted
something on Instagram and wrote all the
copy as we were walking into our last
meeting to me I balanced them by doing
whichever one is needed at the time and
so I don't think about it as balancing
it I think about it as time allocation
like what should I be doing with my time
and I think that that you know you made
a joke of like we did a shoot for a
client and we debated on the phone for
10 minutes where the
should be located for that I think
that's being in the middle right I think
uh pandering to the way companies do
things we just had a meeting where
they're like oh that was provocative us
as
um as the gallery Media Group holds on
all the other things we do us doing what
every other publishing does company does
is not a good idea that's the middle
that's not going to get you to the next
place and so for me I'm just in the
mindset of you know do either doing
humble Dirty Work like the reason I am
the best strategist in social media
out there I really believe this is
because I do both I both sit at the top
of a media company that really does it
at scale for the biggest companies in
the world but at the same token there's
very few humans that put out a hundred
40 pieces of content by hand a week and
reads the con I mean I literally just
replied to Kyle in my comments who and
I'm going to show you because I don't
think you guys believe me when I do
these rants I literally just replied to
Kyle one second before Babin's like
let's do this video like literally what
I was doing one second before then was
replying to like literally like
literally hearted Kyle's comment of I'm
digging the recent pics and quotes man
right like many many people watching
here would argue that my time at this
point in my career of reading Kyle's
comment and Harding it in that minute
was a bad use of my time I think the
dirt
is the reason why I come up with such
good clouds being in the trenches drives
my strategy I live in reality and
practicality not in thesis or ideology
or reading headlines or reading about
people doing marketing uh so I don't I
don't balance it I just do whatever is
needed at that second
Mac you know it's back to macro micro
micro speed I'm just always doing
something
right Bobby like that is the big
breakthrough everybody on the team says
like there's just every second is and so
the reason I can do something every
second is and I don't watch a YouTube
video or stand by the wall water cooler
and talk about the Rockets game for 10
minutes is because I always value the
dirt and so in that half a second that I
had right now in the transition of the
call that I just had about a macro
vaynerx strategy
right the second transition I had before
I started doing a macro thing like the
Vlog
was Harding Kyle's two cents on my last
Instagram post clouds and dirt how much
time do you spend on marketing
you said those four things how much time
do you actually spend on it in a day
Zero sometimes I assume sometimes in a
week how much do you spend on it two
hours great now is the most important
part of this meeting
how many hours do you sleep at night
great so I love the way you said it I
have to have seven so if I wanted to say
go to six so that you pick up five
you're gonna say to me Gary I have to
have seven right
now let's go somewhere else I have to
know what you're doing the other 17
hours I would bet the house that we can
find an hour every day I guarantee you
because you might be working all 17
hours but you might not be working on
something smarter than spending an hour
a day on the thing that you're talking
about do you understand yeah yeah that's
I mean look that's the answer
is time
you know people talk about working hard
and working smart the answer is only
both
you have to work hard and smart based on
your ambition if you want to build a
business for yourself that is like a one
percent life most people don't
understand what building a business for
yourself is it's very special yeah it's
very special trying to build a business
for yourself everybody's doing now
pulling it off
trying to play basketball everybody can
try being an NBA player trying to be a
rapper or a singer everybody's doing
pulling it off trying to be a footballer
an actress got it so you're trying great
pulling it off is hard it takes
everything time and smarts you need
seven I'm glad you said it that way
because this makes this piece of content
more valuable it's the 17 other hours
I'll give you an example A lot of people
drive to work for 45 minutes if they
took a bus for an hour and 15 minutes
they would save money and get more work
done
but do you have the humility to take the
bus versus driving your car I know that
if I can suffocate all of you today to
take 25 of your take-home income this
year and pour it back into two people
who do video and written word
and put it into Facebook and Instagram
ads literally all of you will email me
24 months actually [ __ ] it if you can
start right away literally 25 percent of
you are going to come to me this time
next year right here and be like holy
[ __ ] I've been listening to your stuff
for seven years
your keynote was different in Miami last
year at this time I listened I said [ __ ]
it I don't need to go to Ibiza three
times this year [ __ ] it I don't need to
buy a better BMW this year to make me
feel good with the neighbors [ __ ] it I
don't need another pair of Supremes or
Yeezys I took the money and I put it
into Karen the film woman and Rick the
ad guy
and now my business is 2x this will 100
work even if you suck
on camera have Zero Charisma
are only eight days in the industry this
will work because it is such underpriced
attention
that the ROI will work that if you're a
two
in skill the ads are a 20 in the 10
point scale and it closes the Delta of
you being average if you literally
literally and I've said this for seven
years if you literally literally go
interview the guy who owns the gym in
town the guy who owns the pizza shop the
woman that owns the insurance brokerage
if you literally literally literally
just interview your local community that
you become the local newspaper in
three-minute video form on your phone
you don't even need to hire drock or bab
in your eyes your phone if you literally
take it selfie it and interview the
principal of the school in your
neighborhood you will become the local
celebrity who can then transact on
whatever you're trying to sell that
group if you bring value to people if
you interview the best high school
basketball player literally just that
your business will change or
if you literally just give the advice of
how you got here what you learned if you
shared your thoughts if you do not
understand that you were a media company
that you will not be as successful as
you are today in a decade
and that's not interesting when the
alternative is your four to seven times
bigger the state guys you have to
understand what happened to Blockbuster
and Netflix what happened with Uber and
taxi cut companies what happened with
hotels versus Airbnb is happening with
you as a human in your business
and so when you have the best hand and
you know it because you've been paying
attention and you know how to play poker
you go all in
everybody here is playing Facebook
Instagram social media YouTube
podcasting like they have the best hand
and they're calling
and you're not goading them into getting
all the money you're just folding and
that's this audience so can you imagine
what I feel is going on outside this
Stadium
so this is a call to action for
everybody to do me one favor and I do
think I can get a lot of you to do it
which excites the [ __ ] out of me
please right now listen maybe you've
laid out money maybe you're in the
middle of a renovation maybe you're
paying for your kids college Mazel Tov I
know there's nuances on everybody's life
we're in a position where literally your
take-home income this year is literally
the stuff you're gonna go and do things
with
please from 25 to 90 if you can go
humble please take that money and hire
two people to make a lot more content
for you about you and your business
and please give the rest of the money to
Facebook and YouTube and Instagram and I
fundamentally promise you you will walk
here to this conference next year and
personally thank me emotionally because
your business will change and I know not
one of you has gone all in I'm secretly
worried that I'm gonna get to a place
where I'm not gonna care anything about
business and it's the love of my life
but I can like feel it already I'm like
you know 55 to 75 is going to be some
run
when you actually believe in the value
you're providing
selling promoting
giving for free when you believe
it all clicks the reason people don't do
is because they don't believe they are
either are insecure and structured that
way or they deep down know they're doing
it for the money
people
with expectation
a ton and most of the times I'll say no
because I don't even want to do that but
once in a while I say yes mainly to
stick it to them and teach them A Life
Lesson which is don't come at me and be
like I want to do this awesome thing for
you
and then kind of hover around and always
have this weird relationship with me
where they expect something like we did
something here like if you told me up
front that the reason you bought 10 000
books and did this thing was because
what you really wanted was my face on
your website co-signing your [ __ ]
business well then you should have told
me
because then we could have had a
transaction I think when I get the
praise it's what the [ __ ] does that have
to do with me when I get done I'm like
that's on me and I'll fix it and I think
those you know that was I said it really
quick but it's an accountability it's
accountability and ownership when you
suck and it's passing on the credit
and that's it
that's why I'm winning in life and
that's why I'm always going to win
because when you are a hundred percent
accountable
and you know you're you're garbage when
you're 100 accountable when there's an
issue
and when you pass on the praise when
you're getting it
fundamentally undefeated unbeatable I'm
straight up unbeatable because my head
will never get gassed up enough ever
when I'm getting it good and uh
and I'll never believe it's me and when
it's bad I'll never point the pit finger
to anybody else all your finger pointers
pointing everywhere everybody's pointing
fingers pointing them everywhere it's
everybody's all about yourself the
country your environment your parents
school system your boss your aunt
circumstances are force and of course
there's tragedies and crimes and child
abuse and real bad stuff I'm not saying
it's not real I'm saying for the 95 of
you it's a mindset thing
perspectives everything
grounded in my perspective
behind them too low
it's about them when it's good it's
about me when it's bad that's me
that's what I got for you that's where
I'm at that's my mindset and I never
waver
100 never had my bad days
myself how are you what's your name
Alicia Alicia how you doing I'm good
good okay so me my I want to become um
an author okay just like you amazing and
I have been writing to my passion and I
have I had applied to this riding um YC
team and I spilled my heart out it was
just me
yes they declined me yeah so it's like
it's like they yeah I get it it's like
that's me yeah it's like they're not
accepting me them but it's like
you know honestly guys first of all they
didn't decline you one random person
that read your declined you them
but it's like imagine if I train some
stuff up if I change me they would have
probably took me you're wrong you're
wrong listen to my face I'm telling you
right to your face you're wrong you're
valuing somebody else's opinion too much
thank you
you're wrong
I I'm just telling you this is not this
is not a debate you're wrong do you
understand you're letting one random
person listen do you do you understand
how many people would have hired me none
Instagram in here
go to it right now please
favor go to the end go to garyvee that's
my account go 10 11 posts back you'll
see my report card I was ranked 243rd
out of 254 in my class
[Music]
243 out of 254 in my class you know why
because I knew it was [ __ ] for me it
might not be [ __ ] for you this is
about self-awareness you have to know
who the [ __ ] you are but for me it was
[ __ ] because I didn't need it
because I wasn't I didn't give a [ __ ]
what Saturn how many rings Saturn had
listen to me you can't let something be
valuable more than you you're pandering
to them let them come to you take that
same essay and post that [ __ ] on
Instagram with a photo and see what
happens
see what happens let the market decide
not some [ __ ] middle management
person that read your [ __ ]
good
true and when you're young and 13 and 15
and 9 you think you got to change your
[ __ ] up because you don't know how it's
played that's why I'm here to tell you
exactly how it's played one person read
your story my dear and that person by
the way this whole notion of like you
can do anything and all this stuff let
me just tell you it's stupid hard
reality is most of you are just
averagely talented
right like you're not going to over
index anything too crazy here's the good
news this is not about how much money
you make or how talented you are this is
about being happy everybody here
regardless of how talented they are in
making money or art or what have you has
that they're super into you love Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles
your whole life could be about
Michelangelo
it could and here's what really fits
with me in this internet age you could
have a podcast around Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles you could buy Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtle memorabilia on
Craigslist and Facebook and Etsy and
then flip it on a different platform
because you're so knowledgeable because
that's the pizza eating Leonardo
that I'm just fascinated about what
happens when you go all in on your
passion you're committed to it and you
use the infrastructure of this you
living your life for 80 years as the
Teenage Ninja Turtle expert is getting
funnier to me by the second
making 83k a year in ads on your podcast
the flip some miraculous reason somebody
paid you two thousand dollars to go to a
bush League Comic-Con thing
that person making 62 000 a year being
the TMT expert versus them making 77 000
a year being an admin in a company where
they hate their life nine to five that
Delta is something I will go to the
Grave on because it is what I want to
articulate to everybody the The
Unbelievable level of practicality to do
around stuff you like and here's the big
part
how many people under 40
let me just start with this group
if you just really took what I'm talking
about became an expert at Facebook and
Instagram really understood the fact
that you could take a leap for two years
move back in home move in together cut
your expenses I don't give a sh the fact
that you can do that for two or three
years and if it doesn't work out you can
go back
to getting a job that's nuts
that's nuts the way I do branding I sell
so infrequently uh that I think some of
you that are watching me the hardest
core need to hear this which is it's
okay to sell especially if you believe
in something like if you believe in what
you're selling and that's what I'm
spending a lot of time on now trying to
spend more time on really getting to a
place where I really believe in stuff
instead of just passive not creating so
I wasn't selling because I didn't
believe you know and just letting
everything come to me but as I create
these you know events Vayner experience
a lot of events very big on events
events are so valuable just watching the
4ds crew it's value and like how it's
impacting their business for ten
thousand dollars right there I mean you
see I know you're getting emails
um the wine club like 150 worth of wine
for 55 bucks like I've just locked in
November's it's gonna make all your
thanksgivings ridiculous the conference
500 two hour session in my stomping
grounds good deal compared to like other
conferences that I speak at
um
but you're getting the wine for free or
you're getting the top for free and
you're getting the wine so like I'm very
fascinated because I'm putting more
pressure on myself to create things that
I really believe in
which then allows me to sell more and I
just think for a lot of you selling the
ask the right hook is very difficult uh
your your passive you like the idea of
like feeling good about like giving out
content this and that when you believe
in something
you can sell it and and you should put
more pressure on yourself to create
things that you believe in biggest
problem is so many of you sell you don't
believe in you're just doing it for the
money you're gonna lose
that I don't like I'm 26.
um I want to be uh I I want to say a
marriage counselor but every time I
mention that like oh you know uh what do
you want to do with your life and I tell
people this
um their instant response is you know
how you're gonna do that you're not
married
um
my parents are divorced as if I was
eight since I was eight
um I'm not married I can I can answer
your question right away we're going to
build an amazing yeah we're going to
build an amazing case study together I'm
going to give you I'm going to give you
three names
um and then you're gonna cruise into the
sunset of success which is let's figure
out the three most successful coaches in
the history of sport that everybody
knows of that didn't play that sport
Bill Belichick even though I hate him
with all my guts did not play football
he grew up in the football game right
his dad and what was a coach wouldn't
have you but Bill Belichick did not play
football and he will probably
unfortunately go down as the greatest or
if not one of the greatest head coaches
of all time you don't have to be listen
I think you have to be people have to be
thoughtful I hate 22 year old life
coaches that haven't lived life but if
they if they speak about here's my life
experiences and and why you can
eliminate though very quickly the art
when somebody says to you but how are
you gonna you can't do let me first of
all a couple other questions are your
friends and your circle telling you you
can't do that or are customers that
you're trying to do that with telling
you that they don't want to go with you
because you're not married
uh no this this is more acquaintances uh
people you know that I run into yeah so
listen that's something listen that's a
mistake
like you can't listen to acquaintances
their opinions don't matter
you can't listen to somehow
how do you work out
I'm sorry no go ahead I'm sorry I'm
getting excited you should talk go
yourself
um these
are because I I follow you and I've been
following you for a couple years now and
I do agree what you have to say about
education I do think people are gonna
start moving from you know going to
school and setting their kids to school
to finding I got you I got your answer
I've got your answer a lot of people get
up you know what I'm gonna ask of course
I know I know exactly where you're going
so if you're not going to get the PHD
there's only a few ways to justify
and gives confidence to the End Market
what what why they would jump with you
it's crazy to me that so many people I
was watching 60 Minutes last night in
the background as I was working and the
way that Oprah was justifying the person
was he has a PHD in this and a masters
in that even 60 Minutes use those pieces
of paper to create author Authority in
our society pieces of paper from
businesses and that's what colleges are
has been the authority the only other
people that get Authority are the people
that have gone out and done it and have
people co-signing them right makes sense
so the way and this is why I love
working for free when you don't have a
piece of paper right one of the reasons
I love working for free is working for
free for somebody who is that person in
society whether they got a piece of
paper or their Puff Daddy and they just
did it
becomes the equity that you trade under
once you become great at something right
Andy Andy who's sitting here right now
have every single famous person I see
gives him a lot of street cred right
away not because he got a degree for
personal branding and marketing for
Virginia Tech what degree did you get
political science not because of his
bullsh political science degree from
Virginia Tech but because he went and
worked underneath me and I went out and
did it and I always give him love and
Good Vibes the end
it's not Babin's degree from the USC
School of film or NYU
No Doubt
you know so so what you need to do and
what you need to do is one of two moves
if you're not going to go get a PhD and
have everybody comfortable with it you
either need to go work for somebody that
is the authority and ask all thousands
of people that are authorities and work
for them or okay you need to give your
services for free to five couples crush
it for them and use their word of mouth
and endorsements and uh as your leverage
point the end
here is uh all bent out of shape he just
said uh today is rough to be very Frank
with you Vayner Nation I don't give a
[ __ ] if Tyler or you think today was
rough because I had 17 meetings that he
couldn't be a part of because I'm
actually running a business here I'm not
from some teenage beanie bopper trying
to do a vlog or some influencer doing a
blog or some family that's open for some
free detergent because of their blog I'm
working here Tyler so sorry that your
video blog is rough but let me tell you
what's not rough what's not rough is
we're living through the Great era of
ground shift in marketing and business
everybody in this amazing town of New
York City which is let me just tell you
everybody who's not here
vibrant at 10 pm right now because 98 of
your cities are sleeping
everybody here is their Collective pants
because the ground is Shifting
everything that our grandparents and
parents grew up with everything that we
knew tried and true the stable pillars
of media Commerce uh influence
persuasion the way we make decisions the
things we buy and how what is cool and
what is not is on call
yeah
the world is on call and you know what
that means Hustlers the opportunity is
obnoxious so whether you're focusing on
vlogs
or influencers or how to hack Instagram
stories or how to create Alexa voice
skills or how to create your own podcast
because you see I'm full committed tilt
if you are not following my podcast
the way I call today the the sum up of
all my meetings today none of which you
just watched is that the Earth is moving
there's instability in the foundation of
how it was which makes an innovator like
me really happy and what suffocates all
you be players because you like it you
like it nice slow and stable let it be
very clear with this ending rant that
game is over and the people that are
going to win over the next five to seven
years are going to be very comfortable
and Controlled Chaos so you better get
your speed up you better work harder you
better work smarter you better try
things you better keep your
subjectiveness and your ego at the door
because that slows you down and it
doesn't make you do you better move I
also think that
all of these things that we're talking
about can be scaled right so my career
is going along nicely and then and I'm
winning on email marketing 90 open rates
and I'm winning on Google AdWords the
day comes out I'm buying every wine term
that's working for my dad and then comes
along YouTube
and I see this platform and I say to
myself there's something here
and you can't run ads on it on the time
at the time
so
when I decide to do a show
well I never thought of myself this gift
of you know I thought of myself The Gift
of Gab but more like a good salesman or
you know a class clown that the teacher
kind of liked you know and so I
didn't realize what I was going to be
able to do in that format but I started
a very big show that garnered a lot of
attention and it really really worked
and it really got going and it really
taught me oh my God I don't have to
spend marketing money this attention is
trickling down organically
to my dad's business there's something
here and then Twitter came out and I
started using it to promote Wine Library
TV
and I'm like oh my God
this Friendster Myspace thing is about
to become much bigger this social it
wasn't called social media yet it was
called Web 2.0 Twitter was known as a
Web 2.0 app and
I started using it and Google buys
YouTube for 1.7 billion dollars and I
say to myself oh my God I was right
about this I was right about Google
AdWords I was right about email I'm bet
I'm not a wine retailer I understand
what people are gonna do
I need to become an investor in what I
think people are going to do in 2007 I
invested in Facebook Twitter and Tumblr
and that obviously changed my life my
brother was graduating from college I
was starting to make videos about
business that were catching people's
attention and in 2009 I decided to start
vaynermedia to do marketing for the
biggest brands in the world so I could
learn big business because I understood
Silicon Valley I understood small
business entrepreneurship but I didn't
understand executive Fortune 500 land
and I didn't understand why they were
doing so many silly things in a world
where I thought Netflix Facebook Amazon
were going to be the next big thing and
they turned out to be way bigger than I
even kind of predicted even though I was
predicting the tippy top and so
that's been my career I've written five
New York Times best-selling books around
marketing and
um and consumer behavior and psychology
but what is all this hyperbole around me
mean it means that
I believe that every person who's
watching this right now is me in 2009.
here's what I mean by that I had a level
of success
I was good
I was enjoying myself I was building a
big company for my parents I was excited
to think about what I was going to do
for myself next
but the scale of the Internet by using
the tools completely changed my life
and I believe that what the internet
does is exposes things so I don't think
the internet changed me
I don't think it made me nicer and
stronger at my craft I think it made
more people aware that I was nice and
strong in my craft
and so I think for everybody who's
watching right now I don't think they
realize that if they started producing
content on LinkedIn about what they know
not what you think people want not to
get followers but to put out content of
what you know storytell my grandpappy
taught me when I was 10. this I now did
this for my sales person today that's
the video
you don't have to be an expert I'm not
an expert I'm a person that has
hypotheses and opinions and because a
lot of them became true after 15 years
and I've put the actual business wins on
the board now people look at me in a
different way
but I don't even you know even the
flattering introduction and our talk
beforehand you know she makes me feel so
good but I don't think that makes me
special I think it's just a nice feeling
to be admired you know uh and and I
think when you later humility and
curiosity around being good at a tool
great things happen let me give you an
example
when books came out yeah I'm being
serious now when books came out
clearly and I have no knowledge of this
but this is very easy to understand
clearly there were individuals who
became more aggressive at reading them
and amassed knowledge and my intuition
is the ones that were able to be
practical in operating were able to do
something with that knowledge and
succeed when tractors and Innovation hit
farming
the people that didn't demonize it and
many did many said that's not real
farming because they were fearful that
it was going to take away jobs from
their people which was a nice thing but
they were trying to fight technology
which is always the wrong answer let
there be no confusion if you hear or
feel anything from this keynote and Q a
today please let it be this if you were
fighting against technology you will
lose
it is the history of mankind technology
and the way we live doesn't care about
my opinion or my feelings and it doesn't
care about yours either and so you can
walk around Earth and judge oh it's so
sad that all these kids can't
communicate because they're on the phone
anymore and you could talk about a day
and age when it was simpler and nicer
and all this nobody gives a
and if you don't adjust to the reality
of the situation you will be completely
left behind too many people are
executing or hoping or trying to figure
out how to live in a world that used to
be or the way they wish it was versus
attacking the reality of the world and
here is the reality of the world my
friends
the cell phones that you're all holding
right now or in your pocket are the
remote controls of our society they are
the single most important thing in the
world there's nothing close whatever you
want to happen in life you first need
somebody's attention and then you need
to tell them about it it was called the
newspaper the television and the radio
now it's called a Blog a blog or a
podcast it's the same thing nothing's
changed except one thing your attention
is moving to a new place and leaving an
old place I'm making this very simple
very black and white very basic if you
do not spend next year completely
obsessing over how you become successful
on Facebook and Instagram you will be
disproportionately less likely to win
the ad product on those two platforms
are disproportionately underpriced
and that that is where you should be
trading you are grossly underestimating
what's happening right now
98 of people are grossly underestimating
how good it is right you will look back
at this talk all my content during this
era why am I producing so much content
during this era why am I flying around
the entire world over and over speaking
to this subject it's because I know what
I'm talking about right now
gonna go away
and I think we can all agree I'm not
hedging up here right now
I'm desperately trying to force this
down your mouth
right
you heard it
and I believe that 95 of you will not do
anything about it you'll do enough to
make it feel like you did something
and you will regret not going all in how
many people here play poker
good I don't but if you do
when you have the best hand it's a good
idea to go all in it is far more fun to
die on your sword than to die on someone
else's I'm inspired YouTube we're gonna
make this the episode thing you'll get
whatever you want Tyler but this is the
core of it you just saw it on stage I'm
sorry you just saw it on stage
dying on your sword is better than dying
on someone else's so many of you are
doing things making decisions and
navigating your lives based on somebody
else's thesis you're doing it because
you think it's the right thing because
your dad's telling you it's the right
thing you're doing what you're doing
right now because you're pandering to
your boss even though you don't believe
in it this is how it's going to play out
you are doing things right now yesterday
you made a decision that you don't
believe in or you're smart you did it
because you know how your company scores
here's the problem with disruption and
Innovation right now you're being
rewarded for being a yes person
and in 36 months you're going to be
fired for being a yes person and you're
doing it because you just need the
security of your job I'm telling you
right now if you're watching this Vlog
and you've got like that means you have
a certain DNA please I implore you
please die on your sword not somebody
else's If You're Gonna Lose it's much
more fun to lose based on what you
thought do you know I mean do you know
how many of you are gonna lose on
somebody else's thesis it's going to
kill at you it's going to eat at you
it's going to be the worst feeling so
please
pause this video right now and ask
yourself am I doing my because of me
then you're good whether you're winning
or losing or am I doing it because
somebody else is telling me it's the
right way or I'm subconsciously
pandering to please somebody or
something because I need the short-term
stability figure that out
know it and I
you just need to do something about it I
was born in Belarus in the former Soviet
Union I came to the U.S when I was three
we lived a very humble beginning as you
can imagine the economy wasn't super
great we didn't speak English we had a
hundred bucks I lived with seven family
members in a studio apartment in Queens
so it was super humble as you and you
know obviously my parents are very much
my heroes uh one because my mom is the
greatest parent of all time and two
because my dad worked his face off and
even though I slept under the same roof
literally every day of my life with my
dad in the first 14 years of my life I
literally never saw him because he left
at 7 A.M or 6 a.m and he came home at 10
p.m and he worked seven days a week how
many people here are immigrants or
children of immigrants raise your hands
awesome so this group that just raised
their hands they know that immigrants in
America have absolutely figured out one
of the core Secrets which is you know
work your face off and don't buy dumb
and so that's kind of what my family did
for seven or eight years you know we my
dad wasn't making that much money but a
funny thing happens when you buy nothing
but food at the lowest possible price
and uh save save save save save save and
very quickly only six years after Coming
To America with 100 bucks my dad was
able to buy a small liquor store in New
Jersey we moved to New Jersey that is
where my entrepreneurial career began uh
when I was six I had a five Lemonade
Stand franchise
I uh manipulated my friends into
standing behind the lemonade all day and
that is when I became obsessed with
attention and this is really interesting
as you can see up here I day trade
attention culture and build businesses
at six years old
I would spend my summer days literally
walking up and down the streets of New
Jersey
sitting down on the curb watching cars
drive by so that I could figure out
which tree or post was better for me to
put a sign that said lemonade a quarter
that is DNA that's like somebody singing
That's like somebody throwing a pitch
really like that is just pure DNA I
didn't read a Seth Godin book or go to
Harvard Business School to figure out
that attention was the number one asset
the one thing that combines every person
here from the cameraman back there who
are producing to the industry that is in
this room to me to Mickey to anybody
else that sneaked in the one thing that
fundamentally connects all of us is
before you tell me how great your
product and services you need my
attention so that I listen I am obsessed
with attention I am obsessed with this
device because it has the attention I am
unemotional if it's ruining the kids and
they don't know how to engage or that
you were sad that people go out to
dinner and don't talk to each other
technology does not care about your
feelings
and so I as a human may have some
opinions about Parenthood and and
society and privacy as a human
but as a businessman I am unemotional
and not romantic all I do is follow
where the attention is and I figure out
how to storytell in there to create the
action that I desire
gotta break out of that pattern you
gotta not listen to him and make money
in however way you want listen
listen otherwise you're stuck if you
want to help your mom sometimes the best
way to help your mom is to get out and
then come back and get her out
I get it so honestly honestly and I
respect that listen to me like this mom
you're in a spot right now my mom didn't
have her mom or dad
life was wrong it sucks right now if
when you're 14 it feels like it's your
life forever it's not your life forever
bro you understand surround yourself
with as much positivity to get you
through this chapter
I have no friends I get it bro bro
you've got to be patient it's early I I
noticed forever
I get it but you have to understand
there's no alternative there's only two
choices here you stay under that roof
and each for four more years three more
years two more years or you bounce now
plenty of people bounce to 14. it's not
common in the UK but people do it or you
don't life's about a very simple option
you either do it or don't if you're
gonna under that roof you need to put
your earpods in and listen to positivity
24 7. do you understand when your
surroundings are your insides got to be
positive the fact that you're even here
means you're halfway home
[Music]
DM me right all right you listening
listen to me when it's around you you
have to make it positive in your head
know it feels like it's like it's
forever and it's going to take forever
when you're 14 four more years sounds
like forever but you have no choice you
either bounce or you stay and if you
stay which is more likely which is fine
you've got to put positivity in your
ears do you understand I promise you you
have no other Alternatives otherwise you
just dwell and you go down a spiral that
you don't want to go down you understand
one theme that I really people are like
yo how do I build my self-awareness how
do I build my optimism how do I change
my mindset it's the people around you if
your best friend is Debbie Downer you're
not going to be as optimistic as you can
be if the people that from your town
that you hang out with have no ambition
you're going absolutely nowhere if you
listen to your dad every day about how
the government sucks you're not gonna
love life you've got to audit Your Inner
Circle podcast friends listen to me
listen very carefully to this mashup and
these thoughts because this underlining
tone of who you surround yourself with
apps absolutely fundamentally changes
who you are period end of story when I
hang out with Silicon Valley in 2005 to
2010 I was a different dude when I hang
out in the agency land right now I'm a
different dude when I'm like it when I
was in college at Mount Haida different
dude like you're a different person and
I'm telling you right now this morning
podcast or this podcast because I know
some of you listen to it late this
podcast if I can get one of you one
person listening to this to dump one
loser person in their Circle and add one
whoever's that smiley happiest person at
work that you don't talk to that much
that's at the cubicle around the way or
that awesome like that you know how
everybody has like you have a friend but
their friend like went to college with
them you don't really know them but like
the three times you see them a year
they're positive and like they're doing
things surround yourself with those
people seek out your friend's friend who
brings Positive Vibes and make them part
of your world and cut out your homie
from college that thinks the world sucks
watch with that addition and subtraction
does to your life if you're trying to
reach the decision maker at a retail
organization that guy or gal is also the
same person that I want to reach to sell
a bottle of wine or a book to and that
space in his and her Facebook feed is
only one space
so that is supply and demand I used to
buy that space four years ago for a
dollar for every thousand Impressions
now it's seven the longer you think this
world doesn't exist and you fear
Margaret the longer you don't put money
in the longer I can extract all the
value I've lived this game I'm not a
hero because I took it from three to
fifty million 60 million my dad's
business I actually am a schmuck I
should have spent more on Google
I had it figured out every time you
typed in Cabernet Merlot Silver Oak
Camus Napa Bordeaux I was showing up
first because nobody realized it was
good real estate and it was only costing
me five or ten cents a click and I was
making between seven and eighty dollars
in profit for something that was costing
me three dollars to get you through the
funnel on the average of 60 people
coming and one converting I was stupid
I'm being serious with you I stand here
and have passion about LinkedIn and
Facebook marketing in a B2B environment
today out of regret for what I did from
2002 to 2005 because I should have spent
more it was basic math but I just didn't
understand
because I was young in my career and it
just I don't even know how to explain it
to you when it's too good to be true
it's too good to be true right I'm an
immigrant I was cynical I just didn't
plus I also thought it was important to
do direct mail and local commercials and
magazine I was doing it all but in
hindsight it was the great mistake of my
career
the great mistake of my career was not
spending more money on Google and I
promise you the great mistake of your
accelerated growth for the 80 that just
raised their hand is not taking
advertising on LinkedIn and Facebook
seriously because you don't think your
person is on it I've heard every guys
I've been doing this for 10 years I know
what your excuse is going to be I can't
wait to the Q a I'm going to stand here
I want to but Gary my my target person
is a 63 year old man he's not on it
[ __ ]
of course he's on it who do you think is
spreading all the Democratic and
Republican propaganda on Facebook today
I lost 50 of all the money that I have
people are ditching me because they
don't want to go to the conference
anymore so I've been just full-on pissed
right getting [ __ ] on today yeah that
sounds awesome well today yeah I like it
I like it I like it I'll tell you why
because I even I can tell by your
demeanor that you're gonna be okay the
fact that you realize that that negative
moment has positive impact the question
is why might it happen and that's why
you have to be honest with yourself
I don't know you know but that's you
know I'm pumped that you can have the I
mean you're more positive and half the
people here and it sounds like you're
having a terrible day
you know it's super Rage that's why I
wanted to ask you how do you keep the
positivity in the columnist when
everything
because basically when things happen I
go the other way
so tonight
I just was reminding myself every time I
every time you came and the next person
came I was just reminding my literally
in my own head saying you don't mean I
said it to one of you I said they said
how do you stay humble when you're so
successful I'm like because I know if I
die tomorrow I'll have a good day on
social media
most comments ever on my latest post on
Instagram everybody's gonna be like oh
that was the last one weird and and I
know that all of you will be on with
your life a week later
you have to balance your ego with
humility in the same way when I'm having
my worst day I realize I'm the best
I'm gonna be the best that ever does
this
and so the way I handle things is when
something's going one way I use all my
emotional strength to push the other way
what are you gonna cry for the rest of
your life because the conference got
[ __ ] up
like I just like to me it's just like
look what the [ __ ] going guys
if you're in this room right now let me
just remind you that there are 7.7
billion people literally right now as we
stand here there are women being shipped
to be strippers
in parts of our world right now as we
stand here there are women who are
basically caged mentally usually and are
being shipped to dance on a pole in
Manhattan and in London like do you
understand what's there's there's
genocide going on right now like what do
you think is going on
like we lack perspective your conference
got [ __ ] up boohoo I lost a client
boohoo there's people dying out there
like like so when Americans or Europeans
talk to me about race or gender I'm sad
it's the real life but I remind them
because it's a positive thing cool but
let me tell you about the person that's
ranked 7 billion in the world
they have
it and so I just I struggle like I want
to like I listen I'm weird I think about
things like animals like I don't know
like if you're the best elephant we are
still better than you
like listen you know I got hot on this
about a year ago the 400 trillion to one
it's impossible to be a human being you
won
I don't know how to get upset after that
I keep [ __ ] in perspective right like
you're going to learn from this you
[ __ ] up
I promise you it's failing because of
you
and and when you start owning your
and not blaming other people and I think
this is the kick I've been on lately on
Instagram right like blame yourself you
know why I'm always happy I believe
myself
when you blame yourself for real you're
gonna always be happy
because you don't feel like somebody
else controls you
40 but starting out where most of your
audience is starting out when they're 20
or 30. well it's interesting no joke I
don't know if you saw this I literally
posted a video today to 47 year olds I
did not see that yet so uh to me
everybody's going through different
things you know I to your point in the
last eight 12 to 18 months I found
myself producing a lot more content to
youth than I have in the past which was
usually to more 40 year old business
people
um look I think the biggest thing with
40 to 50 is that it's now you've lived
life and you're still young as
and you're like now what right you have
like an entire second life to live and
it's a very interesting time in people's
lives where they have to be really
retrospective of like how self-aware are
they but honestly I think 40s young man
I really really do and so I would say a
lot of the advice I give to 20 year olds
Maps pretty well to 40 year olds which
is you know take some risks you've
tasted some stuff you know happiness is
the ROI and so you know figure out what
makes you happy is it the pursuit of
money or is it actual money do materials
make you happy if materials make you
happy is that really just insecurity and
you need to have you know a BMW to make
yourself feel good like what's making
you tick but I would say the biggest
thing that I would tell any 40 year old
is you've got 50 years to live please
get the I'm finished or I [ __ ] up like
eliminate dwelling because you're just
starting I really believe that by the
way this is not some motivational
rah-rah I just think it's true I just
think you've got 45 adult years to live
that's 20 more than you've lived there's
just so much opportunity if you're
self-aware you don't try to do things
you can't do
you focus on things you do like you
don't try to be something you're not
if you have self-esteem you're not
scared to put it out the content the
video the picture the audio
because you're not worried if Sally
pants 49 thinks you're ugly you're not
worried that Rick Thompson from a
competitive company says you're stupid
you're just not worried you're not
worried that you have bags under your
eyes or you're overweight or you're
losing your hair you're just not worried
you're you're focused on your
self-esteem you're focused on yourself
you're focused on your self-awareness
which puts you in a position to succeed
and so all of you one of the worst not
worst what are the challenging times in
my career was around 2012 when people
all wanted to be like me and I'm a very
very over the top high energy
personality who's very very comfortable
on video and that is just not going to
be the case for everybody and I tell
everybody and it took me a while to get
to this good answer which I think has
helped people listen my friends if
you're watching this right now and be
like okay I see what Gary's setting up
he's going to ask me to start producing
a lot more content that's the answer by
the way
well I don't want to do video well my
good news Sarah you don't have to do
video
you might for example I'm a terrible
writer if I was a great writer I'd be
writing a lot more because writing on
LinkedIn crushes as a matter of fact my
team loves when I I write all the copy
on my Instagram posts right all of them
everyone every post in my life and they
get pumped when I get motivated and like
write a real good one because we know
the post does better copy is the most
underrated thing in social media today
it drives so much of the success of the
picture in the video so by the way you
might be in audio you might be a talker
but you're insecure about your visual of
how you look or the camera makes you
freeze but you're great with talking so
good there's now Clubhouse an incredible
app you can go and be a thought leader
in there's just recording audio and
posting that on your LinkedIn
LinkedIn for this group knowing who's in
the room
is equivalent to what Facebook was in
2012.
that will lead to incredible financial
and emotional
success to those in here that heed the
call that I'm yelling today period end
of story I could not be more passionate
about everybody here getting very
serious and then what you put out
is up to you you know my recommendation
is that it brings value to people
whether it's entertaining whether it's
informational but I also believe that
stories stories are easier for people
this is something that I'm going to
start talking a lot about a lot more
about I think stories just stories like
life lessons grandma told me and then if
you're good at and I've already talked
brought this up I'm going to bring it up
again because I'm trying to help
everybody here give you some training
wheels if you say hi I'm Karen I'm a
sales lead at this company I this is for
my team but honestly this is for the
broader world because all you sales
leaders I know how it is
you know when I was nine my grandmother
took me to a girl scouts event and Sarah
Johnson did this and my grandma I did
this and grandma told me to do that and
then I did this and me and Sarah Johnson
were best friends in high school and
that's ironic because I had a big Tiff
between Carl and Carla recently on my
team and I did this like my grandma did
that and now they just closed the
biggest account together that story that
should come very natural and by the way
you don't need to call out Carl and
Carla right because that's active you're
in the world right now you could be two
people on my team just think about how
easy that is for what everyone's
struggling with which is well what do I
post
what do I post is grounded in lack of
self-esteem and lack of strategy
period
and so
I'm here today to build your self-esteem
and not in a delusional way I'm just
trying to encourage you to realize how
real this is because the content
creators that build awareness and
audiences will have the leverage in
business whether it's a small narrow
world and by the way this is a small
narrow sector most of the business
people on this call in this thing that's
great actually
the reality is that's great because then
you run a couple dollars in ads on
LinkedIn against targets of companies
that are in your sector and you're
getting exactly who you want I actually
like when groups are narrow because you
can get so much more specific
so anyway I'm just very excited to be
here I want to encourage
everyone to realize the opportunity Evan
thank you so much for having a couple
seconds and being able to tell the
believe Nation a little bit about
empathy wines it means a lot to me that
you would take this valuable real estate
and and time on your channel to give me
some love means a lot it's just good
karma points and so you're just you're
awesome thank you believe Nation uh if
you're into wine at all go to
empathywines.com my whole careers work
was poured into producing a wine that
rivaled 40 to 60 dollar wine for 20
bucks a bottle uh I'm just super excited
about this subscription-based wine
business you can order three six or 12
bottles in subscription form Rose white
red
um if you if you search on Instagram or
Twitter you will be blown away people
are literally like I don't even like
garyvee but the line's good super proud
of the effort thanks Evan for the time
uh wishing you guys all happy and
healthy
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to see the last one on one I did
with yeah read vaynerchuk check the
video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there I'm talking about
something that the world thinks is a
contradiction I don't understand why
anybody should ever verbally dress down
an employee